[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Jeremy Brock welcome to our
fourth screenwriters lecture in
conjunction with Lucy Gardiner Jojo
Charitable Trusts we are as you can
imagine hugely honored to have as our
next speaker the four-time BAFTA winning
two-time Oscar winning writer and
director Alfonso Cuaron his films
include e tu mama tambien children of
men gravity and his latest masterpiece
Roma I will be moderating a Q&A followed
as always by questions from the floor
but before I do I'd like to give a
context to what our Fonz who is going to
talk to he became the first Mexican to
win the Best Director award both at the
BAFTAs and at the Oscars two other
Mexican filmmakers have since gone on to
achieve the same the Mexican new wave
that swept across our screens in the
late 90s and 2000's made the world
acutely aware of the creative talent
coming out of that country the beautiful
storytelling that has emerged from
Mexico in the last 20 years is testament
to Alfonso's pioneering talent and I'd
like to welcome him on stage to talk
about the cultural shift that allowed
such a wealth of talent to emerge from
one place ladies and gentlemen Alphonse
Niall
[Applause]
oh I think what's going to be a
conversation
haha I think was going to be a
conversation so it's just I'm so
prepared to on prepared to give any
speech but no I'm very happy to be here
and as I was as we were talking before
the the reason I'm so excited is that
rarely screenplay is given a place in
terms of the conversation of of
filmmaking there is some much much to go
to obviously to actors and the directors
process and and rarely it's really
explored the process of the screenwriter
I consider myself probably a
screenwriter before I'm a filmmaker and
that is that just as a matter of process
you know a there's a hole is the process
that thought out of making your film
even when I'm at I'm a director as well
and as a director I'm as free as strong
is that thought-out process and that
thorough process is reflected in that
screenplay the a I believe that cinema
is is a language in its own form it's in
its own right is a language that
requires a lot of different tools that
the different tools you know you have
sound you have performance and of course
one of for certain kind of films the
films that I do the narrative films
scream the screenplay is kind of the
fundamental tool but those screenplays
should be serving it's very different to
write serving a literary material
meaning something that is going to be
that the
the purpose of that is to be read in a
book as opposed to something in which
the goal and if and the end of it is to
be seen on the stream so I think as a
screenwriters we need to recognize that
film language how that lead that that
this particular particular art in which
narrative is constrained in time and
that's something soap that I found it
very beautiful because when you're
reading a book a piece of a novel a you
get in merits you get lost in those
pages but you're not bounded by time and
what I find is that the sense of time
bounces with it
now when we are experiencing a film we
are in one hand lost in that in that
universe in that in that experience but
by the same token we are breathing that
experience for as long it lasts you know
book and lasts you can read a book in
two days or in in in four weeks a film
you end up watching just the length of
it and I think that that's something
that is so important in the process of
screenwriting is that sense of the
experience that we're going to have in
real time and I mean I prefer frankly I
prefer to expand this into a
conversation and more importantly to
have the conversation with with you if
that's okay
[Applause]
I'm going to steal this to steal the tea
yes great
and again I'm sorry I was so imperfect
that no not since I know but cozy huh
they're cozy um so first of all our
fonts oh thank you so much for taking
the time out to come and talk to us you
mentioned there the the importance and
the significance of time in film and in
the filmed experience can I begin by
taking us back a bit to the beginning of
your career and I want to just begin by
asking you you studied philosophy then
you studied film in Mexico what at that
time when you were young and unknown
were your cinematic inspirations what
were you looking to who were you going
to hear talking or what what films were
talking to you at that time and
inspiring you
well the bents of which I was talking
I'm talking about when you were a
student at university study or what I
was yeah that that yeah the thing is I
was studying philosophy on film at the
same time right and so one thing was
pretty much informing the other the
other and this was the late 70s and so
there was a lot of in terms of cinema
there was what it was the the new German
cinema yeah you know the new Volvo was
still kind of winging but there was the
post novel yeah we'll both people like
Alan tanner
and there was together with that there
was all these crazy experiments from
from from from the Germans yeah so it
was pretty much a lot of European that
the whole period was marked by a lot of
contemporary European filmmakers and
this beautiful period of the
of the Italians of the seventies right
I'm talking about the table Yanni yeah
particularly table young who were like
my favorite yeah yeah
you've talked in the past in interviews
about your personal experience of life
in Mexico you've used the word being
scarring can you talk a bit about how
that translated into the first film that
you that you cover up with your brother
Carlos e tu mama tambien yeah what was
the inspiration for that film and how
did that screenplay emerge from the
memories that you brought to it how did
that evolve well but there was a
completely from period that my studying
years that was probably 12 years after
yes and and during that period there's a
funny thing about how life works because
that at that time I was kind of record
recovering or trying to recoup I was
very into American cinema of the forties
right practically the 40s maybe a
thirties I was in love with Lubitsch
yeah and I'm Billy Wilder Billy Walden
IL Dimond yeah yeah yeah and they
co-wrote of course they quorum yeah with
martinis a lot of marty with a lot of
martinis yeah yeah that's a reason I
wanted yeah yeah the so it was this
whole idea of rhythm yes you know and
with Carlos my brother he's he's a
writer and and we would talk so much
about rhythm yes and and we wanted to do
something that was precisely honoring
that sense of rhythm mmm you know it was
and that was I would that was the focus
but it was it was a period I have to say
I am a late bloomer in film I get Mario
filmmakers that from the first film they
already get it you know it took me a
while to get it you know it took me many
many many many years to start and
having got it yes you know yeah but but
but to start having the sense and the
notion of it and I'd say my early in my
early films it was always just trying to
really do something that worked you know
yeah if I was just so satisfied even
with Lubezki my collaborator the
cinematographer we would say if we do
one scene that is good we're happy yeah
yeah when because you talked about
rhythm often screenwriters talked about
the music of a screenplay and there are
analogies I think that work very
effectively with with music there is a
sense that one is orchestrating a story
can you can you talk a bit about how the
storytelling of e tu mama tambien
evolved so what really strikes me about
it as a as a as a screenplay even though
the screenplay is invisible
is that you you you are telling a very
intimate story against a backdrop that's
as important so the environment of their
world the disjunction between privilege
and poverty the rites of passage that
those boys go through with Louisa did
you did you evolve what's become
something that I recognize in your work
this parallel between character and
environment did you did that evolve as a
conversation with Carlos was that
something that you were consciously
imprinting in your script or did you
learn it as you went along yeah in that
they the thing is when when the way that
it to mama tambien happen was after many
years of her story of that I consider
maybe that I lost many years of my
creative life being at the allowing
myself to be to follow the siren the
siren siren or the siren call of
Hollywood and II and that was him from
precisely by going back to the reasons
why I loved film
I won one day I was very frustrated and
I went we still have video shops at the
same other time
you know give you places and and I was
living in New York and went and I just I
just rented a bunch there was like
20-something videos I locked myself in
my house and great delivery food in New
York by the way uh and I watched film
after film of the films that I I would
just go to the video thing and start
getting stuff yeah that I recognized
that there were the reasons why I love
cinema
yes and I was watching one after the
other and it was the recognition again
of this thing of film is not just this
thing of illustrative features you know
is that a that pictures that illustrate
stories film is something way more
complex than that and he and also the
recognition that cinema doesn't owe
anything to to literature no absolutely
or to or to drama or to painting a
cinema is way more similar to music
completely agree you know is it's an art
that flows in time that also is an
abstract language that that flows with
fields but it has the added complexity
that at the same time one is still
having to stitch together a narrative
that's coherent and that's one of the
beauties of what I feel you've achieved
in your work but I can see it nascent in
in eg mama tambien the ability both to
control rhythm and tone but to also tell
a story that's incredibly enthralling
the story of these boys and their sexual
awakening and the story of their rights
a passage from a kind of innocent sexual
bravado yeah but this simple thing
because I remember when I start writing
with catalyst after I finished that
period I called my brother and said hey
let's write screenplay
yeah common come to your left right swim
yeah said okay thank you
and and we start talking about this in
the basic premise of it oh mama tambien
of the two kids going with an older
woman it's something that we have for 10
years or 12 years actually before doing
my first film was one of the choices -
yes you know to do and I'm glad we
didn't do it because we start talking
about that and and and we start talking
about how by itself how uninteresting
uninteresting it was that it was just
yeah it was it was a silly funny story
yeah the front movie story yeah the
front yeah and but we start talking is
when we start talking about it was more
interesting to explore who these
characters were and to explore how their
social class and the social context
inform characters yes and how these
characters by the same token inform that
environment of because coming back to
your question and that's what we started
the whole writing process was to be
conscious about those about detention of
those to stay aware of those to say of
those two layers implicit in that is an
anxiety that sometimes overwhelms our
the screenwriters because you're trying
to cold an awareness of of it as a piece
of music and it's a something that's
totally very pure unto itself but at the
same time to tell it tell a story one of
the things you do in e tu mama tambien
which i think is very bold as you use
third-person voiceover and I'm
interested to know as a writer whether
you or as writers whether you deploy the
third-person voiceover from very early
on or whether that was a discovery no it
was it was already well was the part of
the reason why doing the voice-over i
remember when i mentioned carlos and we
need a voice-over he's a refused and i
refuse to do this screenplay says i'm
not going to do the one or years and
then said well-known it's not the 100
years and and I said there's a piece of
music music that I love him he loves
from from a German composer called
fencing yes
that is called treated twisting in which
the is such AB has this beautiful
interludes of very melodic stuff and
then certainly those pieces are brutal
interrupting and there's this narration
of this shot of this child and what it
happens is it just takes you out
emotionally together into a more
reflective state and then springs back
into these interludes you know and and
the result of that is an amazing
emotional depth and then we start
talking about breath you know and you
know the whole break I don't know in
English how you call the distance any
nation
Dehlia nation that the birthed and
alienation yeah you know how taking you
out to engage in turn in rationally into
into the whole process and then he start
saying okay okay and then and then I
show him I think was masculine feminine
right that he hasn't seen and Houston
watching says okay I get it I get it
stop stop lecturing and telling me and
and and that was the process and it was
from there in the in the in the
screenplay in the screenplay described
that then the writer comes out with any
out with no other sound yes yes it's
very nice still actually the sound is
killed and then the voice comes in yeah
it's killed for a few seconds yes and it
has it has precisely that Brecht in
effect of taking you out for a second
because you're aware that nothing's
happening and then the voice cuts in
there's a particularly we haven't been
able to bring the clip up unfortunately
for for reasons of copyright but there's
a there's a there's a really lovely
moment in the car I'm gonna describe it
if I really you have what copyright I
don't know what's happened but anyway
we're not allowed to show it which is
very very frustrating so I'm gonna paint
a picture with words there is there is
the moment in the car where Julio and
Tanika
boosting to Louisa about their manifesto
yeah and then there's a moment of
silence and then the voiceover tells us
about their private inhibitions their
intimate inhibitions the loose seat for
me that's one of the most extraordinary
moments in the film because it deploys
voiceover as both alienating but
incredibly intimate and incredibly
telling about the boys in the writing is
that in the screenplay is that it's how
written is that and how much did you
discover that as you have worked with
your actors all of that was all of that
was written in the screenplay
good they are the this is exactly but
this is something that I think people we
were talking about this weren't we
earlier it's and what will address it
again with Roma but it's something that
it's a it's a misconception about the
screenwriting process particularly with
authors like yourself that that they
that that in some way or other vision is
ultimately the property of the director
on the set whereas in actual fact what
you what you do in the screenplay is to
master the structure and the dialogue
and everything so that you can then
liberate yourself does that make well
yeah totally I mean is is and it's two
things is the screenplay but as
important the screenplay is the
thought-out process yes you get to that
screen yes and the more thought-out the
whole thing is as a director when I
arrived to the set I'm free you know I
like then I can improvise yes you too
mama tambien then we would be free to
improvise most of the time coming back
to go ahead we would immerse a full
circle going back to the script yes but
but also even if you find new things are
only because everything was soft thought
out and you have this amazing safety net
yes you know in which you can fall and
you're going to be fine
you know I'm interested in when you
mention improvisation um when I work
with American actors they very often
treat the script as a rough guide which
is deeply frustrating if you've spent 15
or 20 drafts is there a sense that that
the improvisation is as much an
opportunity for the actors to find their
character you say that they come back to
the screenplay how often in your
experience of improvisations changed the
nature of the scene that you were you'd
written beforehand it's not about
changing the nature of the scene is
about making it a life you know you one
thing is also I recognize I'm writing I
have my I have my conception but then
I'm going to be dealing with humans yeah
they have their own ways of moving yes
and always of talking in which sometimes
the rhythm that I'm setting in the page
are not compared yeah it's and by the
way I'm not tarantino Turrentine is
amazing doing that you know he has he's
a writer that is about the rhythm of his
dialogue yeah you know a my approach is
a different approach is is it's about
trying to find the rhythm of the
character right you know and the you
need to mamata mean very often what
happened is that Carlos and I we are
older than Kyle and Diego and they were
just making fun
Garlan Diego of our slang right right
and then they would change to their to
their you know this long and it was
fantastic yes by the way I'm so happy
because now younger people are making
fun of their slang yeah yeah
so the yeah then so that kind of stuff
you know I need to my my time being what
would you is you know with improvisation
low heat oh mama tambien was that here
the script here the pages this is the
dialogue now and if it was all the time
running it each one of the scenes we say
we're going to improvise like one minute
or two minutes before the scene begins
yes
then we engage into the scene and you're
we're not going to cut you kitten
creepily improvising until I cut yes and
that was more the improvisation yes yes
yes I understand and that improvisation
sometimes would inform something that
was already written yes you know but it
was in the context of what was already
there sure sure you've I mean we've
touched on this but in all your films
environment is as important as the
characters and never more so than in
children of men let's talk a bit about
that film and how that development
process differed from ET mama tambien I
know that obviously for a start it's PD
James novel so it's an adaptation rather
than public domain or personal how was
the experience of developing that
screenplay different from e to mama
tambien for you as a writer it was not
that different because I never read PD
James book right you heard it here first
yeah what I read was a synopsis that was
sent to me one page yes and it triggered
no and I found it the whole thing
brilliant yes and it triggered this idea
I was very intrigued about what was it
was 2000 and year 2000 and I was very
intrigued about the themes that were
going to shape the new century yeah and
when I read that and it was very
serendipitous because he it happened at
the same time when I read that I said
wow this is an amazing opportunity to
talk about this and immediately a movie
came in my head and I start like the
mental process and of of drafting how
would it go yeah and so I start working
with team sexton a collaborator writer
collaborator
and and and Tim said should we read the
book and says I don't want to read the
book because I don't want to the tool
from this idea yeah he says but you read
it and maybe if you say that think that
there's something relevant let me know
and and and he said you know there's
another screenplay was written says I'm
not interested but you read it if you
want
so he read the stuff and says okay so
says well there's the book that is
absolutely brilliant is really good but
has nothing to do with what we're doing
right you know is the character of
Julianne Moore is the one who's burning
the baby right different there are no
immigrants yeah it's about you know it's
more about this authoritarian society
you know more like like a leader more
kind of Orwellian leader that is rolling
the whole thing and I was interesting
about making a democratic society that
is going to the bird you know to the
edge of things yeah it's a little bit
like today yes and and the and about
immigration all the solids and the
scribbling was just like straight
adaptation of the north of the nose is
not even that good so let's just stick
to the plan and from then on it was just
about it was as a similar process
because the process was about how we
were going to form all these other
themes you know because I was doing a
lot of research about what what was
shaping you were really me crying and
John Gray when Jean Grey and yeah yeah
the good mister yes John graden great a
very neat list ik John Gray is brilliant
yes
brilliant yeah and people like Todorov
and since Aiken yeah and such as a skin
and a lot a lot of thinkers and a and
that started to inform yes the whole
background the whole thing also they
certain we wanted a lot of this stuff
just be you know like no I don't know if
it's symbolic of metaphorical elements
because there was a lot of also it'll be
the Foucault and yes and and and and an
echoing day right in the process so the
and as we were doing that the as we were
doing it it was about engaging the two
stories you know the foreground the back
foreground and background story so
making one and the same yeah which i
think is a it's a feature of your work
coincidentally you mentioned all those
thinkers that you were working with I
know that our audience often asked this
question about research some
screenwriters find it a black hole into
which they never remote you know never
come back into the light because
research can overwhelm you how do you
deal you with what you beautifully
described once as the tapestry of
information which I loved as a
description of research how do you deal
with the necessary moment where you draw
that down into a document how do you
stop yourself from flying off into the
research and never returning what's
what's for you the process do you write
treatments do you write structure how do
you bring all those notes down to a
script well yeah that's very dangerous
I've been lost yeah we'll another
triangle we all have yes it's a Bermuda
Triangle is really terrible
yeah when things have been good it's
been like in children of men or even
gravity in which before anything else it
was like strong concept a strong idea of
the narrative the initiating idea you
know the narrative and how it was going
to flow from being a to set yeah and and
even put him down in paper some of that
stuff yes
and then the research starts to inform
to is
no no because sometimes inform but
sometimes then their research start
taking the foreground and you and and
your characters the background but just
following that structure that you're
already put right before doing Roma a I
was not going to do wrong I didn't know
was going to do Roma I was ie for a
couple of years I develop a project with
my brother Carlos that dealt with humans
100,000 years ago early humans right
know they're not being true was more a
domestic drama yep but a hundred
thousand years ago
have you read sapiens evil Aurora's book
yeah yeah yeah yeah well that was yeah
one of ya know that came at the end of
my research you know because I was more
he talking with with amazing people here
the at the natural natural natural
history muzeum and really bunch of books
of very specific things about early
grains yes or early or early theories of
language theories of how language was
created books about just fire yeah
cooking and stuff like very very
specific things so much someone also
relation net-net near-total said is the
other subspecies of humans and all the
others you know yes there are millions
and all of those other guys and it's so
much that then we start writing the
screenplay when I felt that I had all
this knowledge yes and what is happening
is that I was so obsessed about all of
that information to be conveyed yes in
the screenplay
yes and at the end I got lost you know I
there was the story more or less that I
have we had set up to do except there
was it was kind of dry it was
of it was not making release it was
making sense a lot of sense but he he it
was I didn't find the angle no I stopped
finding the angle you know I find it
interesting but I I want to go back to
that story eventually but now free
myself from all of that and and that
happened right before Roma and that's
the danger of it you know is they I
think that research it's an amazing yes
is this tapestry in which you access you
know but it should not be the one lead
in the game so you you so so you you you
you reach the hiatus with that project
and then you went on to Roma will come
on to Roma in a moment I just want to go
back to children of men and another very
powerful disjunction that you deal with
in a lot of your work between privilege
and poverty and there's a moment in
children of men where Theo and Nigel are
talking about the art that's collected
gonna correct cetera ostensibly to save
it for humanity but really as Dacor and
and there's a moment in roma and if you
haven't seen roma it's a masterpiece and
i will try not to put too many spoilers
in but there's a moment where the forest
is on fire and the privileged members of
the party are still drinking cocktails
and some of them are just staring at
this devastation in a kind of Numb way
you've talked about green spaces and
about the importance of people breaking
out and thinking more collectively can
you talk a little bit about where that
comes from in your life and how
important that is to you well I I guess
that has to come it comes just from you
know one one experience informs an
experience I come yeah Mexico is a
continent which do you have
is-is-is it's impossible to go through
Mexico and not to see contradictions all
the time
yep you know not to see the most amazing
beautiful places and the most beautiful
expressions of generosity together with
misery and atrocities
you know developed world is different
because the developed work out sources
that misery yes yeah yes the a and has
created these green zones that that
those green zones even even in the
developed countries are becoming
narrower and narrower and narrower
because those winds zones used to be the
the countries by themselves and now even
each country is becoming needed to have
their green zones because there's
already stuff going on outside those
green sounds so when you do you know
you're growing in a society that is so
obvious what is going on around
yeahthere's makes you wonder yes you
know one of the things you did in in
children and men was I believe you and
your cinematographers it's agreed that
you wanted to try and make London as
much like Mexico City as possible
and I'm sure it's no joy to you to
discover how clairvoyant that film was
because here we are 12 years later and
you know the immigration crisis and the
climate chaos that we now have right
around us was there in that film
yeah but the word people were warning
about that for decades
yeah but very few people were listening
yeah yeah but it was no cat it was
another topic trend figures yes and the
the what is amazing is that now
everybody even people sending children
of men look at them you know I was just
these people were talking about that
like two decades ago and now it's
happening they all of this thing that
we're living were completely was
completely predicted to they could say
immigration environment
a fiscal thing of the outer if the
populism and elitist authoritarian state
I mean this is reality really no no it
is no there are no news you know now
it's not news you you while you were
developing shorter the men you directed
a Harry Potter and I mean I mean I don't
really want to talk about Harry Potter
but I wanted to ask one question with
regards to that just in terms of
storytelling and to ask whether there
were any elements of the storytelling
that you were engaged in that influenced
you as you as you as you went on or
whether that was a bespoke experience
did their did you take anything from
that experience from Harry Potter was a
storyteller oh it was just a joy so that
first of all you you were you know
you're engaging into into something that
has so much goodwill yes
yeah so there's a joy to do that yeah
you know you're engaging something that
that is beloved that the the source
material is absolutely brilliant and my
only concern was rather than to do a
fantasy as it was in the previous two
films it was more to try to to
understand these characters as people
that will exist yes you know the great
thing what I love of the JK Rowling's
books is that everything has a reference
to real life and that was the process of
doing that you know and it was for me
they were the challenging thing is I was
not in was I had never done and I was
not used to do films that or that have
so much scope in terms of characters and
stories and so much plotting and and and
that was that was so much fun
I had to say that from the narrative
system yes yes is very joyful yes you
know and besides that it was as a
director it was just my kindergarten for
visual effect
yeah and no and yes brilliant it was
used and another side side effect is
that children of men was the film I was
going to do before Harry Potter and they
didn't want to do it yeah and after
Harry Potter they gave me the green
light oh yeah that was very good the
magic of Harry Potter magic väri pocket
so talking of visual effects gravity now
I'm interested again as always here at
this particular series in in the in the
process of developing that as a
screenplay that the thing that comes
across so powerfully importantly is the
theme of grief and how grief is
expressed visually by a world without
anchors and the world in which death is
or even annihilation is split seconds
away can I ask you about how that
screenplay evolved with your son Jonas
and how you dealt with the fact that you
didn't have the conventional tropes of
story plot narrative that say you have
in Harry Potter how did that come about
and what did you do to meet that
challenge in the screenplay
well that that I owed to Hannes and
actually the stories that I he wrote a
screenplay of another film that you
think he directed called this year - and
here they very early draft and I was
reading that and said this is brilliant
because he was making a big political
statement in the context of a chase and
unstopped chase film you know and the
funny thing is is one of those films
that now when he came out four years ago
so it was kind of not really thinking
about anything top and now there are
time to pick up and that because of
everything that is happening in the in
the US border mexico-us border yeah so
and I said well this is career
you know I would love to I would love to
do something like this bold as this and
because he kept on saying look I like
you your films are alright this is just
it's just that you know is you tend to
be very kind of rhetoric and I get bored
with that right is it and the whole
challenge was okay how to do a film in
which we could convey the information or
the emotion or the thematic elements
without talking about them you know and
and and then we took at the point of
reference we took we start talking about
doing this and as well let's do this but
what if we do these in trying to bring
it in a big scope yeah you know in a big
scope but at the same time to make a big
scale but at the same time making it
absolutely into the intimate story about
a very intimate story and we were
talking a lot about dead man escapes by
Breslin you know in which is a film that
is about a man escape in a prison that
thematically is about many other things
you know but in reality that's the
framing device yeah but in reality what
you're watching is and actually a quite
exciting story about the man escape in a
prison and that was the point of
departure for gravity and it was about
that it was these things he said is
let's make the images count yes
you know let's make the images be the
part of that thematic elements that that
that you sometimes do in to rhetoric
with characters yes and again not
wishing to bang on about screenplays but
presumably all those visual images that
are so rich and the very stripped-down
cinema that that's very very very low on
dialogue of any kind presumably that's
all written in but before you start
shooting something as massive as that I
imagine well is you have any choice
because some something was kind of power
and sometimes frustrating of gravity is
that we were constrained by the
technology right so we had to everything
even the performance Sandra Bullock that
I admire her performance because she was
so constrained about about timings about
rhythms about stuff that was already I
mean we we had done a draft with Sandra
doing a voiceover just like reading the
whole thing yes to try to get her
cadence and her Britain but then she had
to reproduce not exactly same
performance but the timings yes you know
so everything was very constrained so
there was a lot of technical constraints
around yes a lot of them sure and one of
the themes that runs through all your
work but is particularly vivid in
gravity's for want of a better word the
notion of incarnation of birth rebirth
of stillbirth there's there's the
extraordinary moment in children of men
whether that christ-like baby walks
through the war zone and everybody just
stops and then there's Sandra Bullock in
the fetal position and then in Romo
there's that there's still birth can you
talk a little bit about what you're
exploring when those images occur to you
what is it that's bringing those ideas
into the films that you write well a lot
of that is instinct Trull yeah he
recently someone comment about those
things and the funny thing is I was not
really that aware of that or the
connection of those things yeah this
also so it's an enzyme one comment that
most of my films finishing in the water
and I have a noddy's know is that but I
am very I'm very aware that and another
thing that my own explanation is they
have very little imagination I have some
things I think I think again I think
people would just be the
let's talk a bit about Roma and I'm
aware that we should give half an hour
to our friends here because I know they
want to talk to you just briefly on Roma
that's an intensely personal film what
do you do to meet the challenge of
drawing down memories into a
multi-layered complex story what was the
challenge there for you in the screen
writing because memorial material from
memory can very often rather like
research take you down a rabbit hole how
did you control the material in the
writing this is contradicting everything
that we talked about because the my
process of Rama is unlike any other
process I've done in any other film yet
in any front of of my filmmaking
experience not as a writer director even
it cinematographer anything right the
present Rama was when it manifested the
idea yeah he had three pillars and when
those are things that are respect and I
don't I don't move unmovable when I have
some idea manifests comes with certain
pillars and you used that they are there
you one is that it was of about this
character Cleo based upon one one person
you know that a woman who brings me that
is part of I'm part of her family a that
the process that tool was going to be
memory and that it was going to him
black and white those were the only
three things and so the process start to
be memory and and that it was about all
these research that usually do in books
and talking with experts was just like
getting lost in memories and the thing
with memories is that is like this
corridor with many like with with an
infinite number of doors yeah that each
doors that you open leads you to another
infinite corridor within anything
number of doors and you get you keep on
going from door to door and you get lost
in in what borkus talks about called
stay the place of the gallery of shatter
opaque mirrors yeah
because you start getting lost in a door
after door after door after door and I
allow myself to get lost you know and as
I was getting lost a key where each new
new details were and and is the thing
once that you open a door is just that
another many other memories manifest you
know is he it was kind of very
interesting and more interesting when I
start bouncing those memories with the
real-life clay yeah and just and then
learning about her memories yeah and it
was a whole process like that and when I
felt that I had and you know that I have
rich like that point I I you said to
write to the right and I wrote the whole
thing and this is the thing I've never
written a screenplay for for more than
three weeks I believe that screenplay
you write in three weeks or 30 years
there is no time in between everybody
technology is that is the and I'm
talking about the first draft obviously
so sure but in Roma there was only one
draft because I decided that what I was
going to do is sit and start writing
without any consideration to length any
consideration to character structure any
kind of structure plot points or
anything just sit and write almost like
a automatic writing or me free and
trusting been responsibly and not for
very arrogant to think that I have
developed a narrative muscle throughout
the years yeah that would would take
care of everything
and I would just write I wrote for three
weeks
I finished the screenplay and I never
read it again
and nobody ever read that screenplay not
the actors not the crew nobody read the
screenplay the only person who had the
only one was my partner David Linda from
participant films that says he said well
I need a screenplay just because of
insurance otherwise I cannot pay the
money is it says yes but it's for your
eyes only I said yes for my eyes only
just give me a draft and that and gave
it in the draft it was in Spanish he
doesn't speak Spanish so it was and I
never I mean I opened this I would open
the pages but I would never read the
script Lee from a2 said to check
structure stuff like that you know and
because I didn't want anything to taint
the process I didn't show it to my old
collaborators like Alejandro Gonzalez
Inarritu about the Torah Bible Patrick
offski and or Carlos my brother I didn't
want because I knew that they would give
me amazing suggestions that will make me
kind of sidetrack and I didn't want
I just wanted to preserve the purity of
those memories and the way they were
it's a supremely confident thing to do I
think and it's manifested in the film
which is exquisite
so Bravo can we can we take questions
from the floor because I know they'll be
very eager you remember we're going to
just show the religion
could we just bring up a page of the
screenplay and for me it's important to
mention these because we were having a
conversation just before we came out and
the nature of the conversation was about
how detailed Alfonso's screenwriting is
and how important it is to get rid of
forever the misconception that something
is detailed and beautiful as roma just
happens on set I wonder if those that
meet misconception
a lot of that happens in these female
films that I know filmmakers that are
writer directors that that that that
that those are the REC toriel choices if
your reader Guillermo del Toro
screenplay every single detail of
anything of the character or the the
laboratory or anything that they the
labyrinth of the palace labyrinth that
you would say okay that's the director
working with a designer know everything
is so precisely the strived yeah here
the thing is if we stop for a moment
because you bring it down a bit
yeah yeah this is the same image in
which occur in through the garage and a
if when you see the film dual sees is
Sabha is there's a lot of different cuts
and everything as a director I didn't
have to do anything but used to follow
the screen tears you know and and I
think it's it's important because the
feel for its aroma and they asked me if
those are directorial choices and I said
no those are writers choice yes in
dramas filled with a lot for gram
background a lot of description of what
is in the background and everything is
in the screenplay
yes the film is very oral there's a lot
of there are a lot of sounds going on
sound is actually a character in the
film and all the sounds are described in
the screenplay you know I mean there's
stuff that then you are looking for
locations and and you get informed that
you have but you it does are really
little things that you add here and
there yeah the whole thing the core of
everything is already described in the
screenplay
yeah and I think it's very important
because it's a misconception of this
sometimes what is the writer and what is
the director well this is a triumphant
expression of how important screenplays
are no given talks about the waltz you
know about the music that is there
there's a they the engine shuts off and
with it the music you know like it's a
it's when they
the world speaks of the rhythm you know
like all of that is what's what's
remarkable for those who've seen the
film and even for those who haven't is
that this is the first time a character
is introduced it's that the father and
this moment in the film is so predatory
so animal in its power and it says so
much about the man we have not yet seen
walk out of the car and inform so much
of what then follows and thank you so
much for sharing that with us because
it's a triumphant expression of what
screenwriting
should be about is it alright if we so
we're going to take mics around and
we'll start there second Alfonso thank
you very much for sharing your
reflections I'm just curious to know
about legacy and also what you're doing
to preserve the future of the you know
because obviously there must be writers
out there in the mexican film community
are still trying to make get their
voices heard I mean of you are you
mentoring people are you and in terms of
how does the how is the local film
industry doing at the present time well
in Mexico as opposed to the the period
that I was living that my by the making
films in my generation was very
difficult even more difficult to the
generation before mine now there's a
very this an immense industry in Mexico
and that's good and bad because in many
right now there's it's very good in
terms of their jobs you know and that's
fantastic
a lot of this stuff is not necessarily
great there's a lot of series going on
and none of them not all of them amazing
you know and what happened there by
program there's so much job going on is
that there's a certain sense of
discipline that gets lost
you know because rather than people that
rather stay into one position and
learning
craft before moving into another let's
say another position very soon they
become heads of departments like that
happens with technicians you know rather
than learning the craft properly and
being on their you know assisting
someone who knows a lot they very soon
they have the opportunity to move on and
becoming the head of department and then
what happens is that he went to move
into being a head of the permanent but
not with all the knowledge that she
should have so it's a it's a it's a
great thing at some time there's a bad
side effect nevertheless there's from
the standpoint of the creators it's so
them exhibiting what is happening right
now is really remarkable I mean it's uh
I believe that the young generation of
filmmakers is the best generation of
filmmakers in Mexico probably in the
history of Mexico you know and they have
an immense confidence you know and and
and that is fantastic did the whole
thing of Mexican cinnamon my generation
and preview and the previous generations
there was a lack of really narrative
understanding and now narrative of these
the young generation is kind of second
nature you know and some are really
exploring very interesting thematic
elements I'm I think that I'm not
worried about the legacy of of Mexican
cinema somebody was we got a mic over
here I promise we'll go further up yeah
hi I was curious when it comes to
because a lot of I think a lot of people
are very impressed by a lot of technical
things that happen in in your films when
it comes to the cinematography and stuff
so I was curious about when you're
writing because you know you're going to
direct do you and your writing process
think about how you're going to I know
technically approach things and I
suppose second part of that question be
do you think you would write differently
if you weren't going to direct the know
is I
don't think technically when I'm writing
you know that's the joy of writing that
you're not constrained by technique I
that there's sky's the limit when you're
writing so it's fantastic guys in many
ways my favorite the process of getting
to writing maybe not my favorite but
ones that I'm writing is just you get
into this sound and so much fun
the a but the whole thing of the
description is the same I have
collaborated with other with other
people writing or co-writing stuff and
what happens is you just describe you
just try to describe this thing is not
to be read is to be seen you know and
and you try to describe the as much as
possible and then I have seen stuff and
the choices that all the record stuff
that they do and it's great but then I
recognize that it has nothing to do with
a visual I was imagining but it does
with a rhythm that you're setting on the
page you know in terms maybe did a shot
or the thing in a complete different way
but did a shot you know it did that or
let me put this way did the moment you
know convey that moment and it's about
that when we're writing were conveying
those moments and so I think is that the
approach is exactly the same in many
ways I don't think I'm directing when
I'm writing I would be very limited you
know and and I want to be free when I'm
writing it's a wonderful answer is there
anybody with a hands up further up there
there yeah I've got you remember Jason
was gracias
the main question is like with people of
your caliber we are seeing so many doing
projects on like streaming platforms and
things like that do you feel there still
can like enough sense of wanting to give
a shot in your voices to can like move
into the streaming platforms or do you
think
we should try as newer voices going
through the normal path of collect
smaller production so on and then reach
out for streaming or do you think
there's still enough room there for
newer voices to develop and to push
forward and drive I think that this is
something that is way greater than
platforms and and theatrical that is
cinema cinema is what is important the
other stuff are the the annoying
considerations of of showing our films
in in any moment of of history that I
mean right now is the conversation
between streaming and theatrical years
before was just the consideration of
trying to get your film into a
theatrical release you know it's I I
what I only difference I see is that
right now is there's a fight in which to
two things that had nothing to do with
cinema it's two economic models are
fighting and and eventually is going to
come into a balance but I don't think as
a filmmaker we should concern about
economic models we should consider you
know concern ourselves just in terms of
film its storytelling somebody up at the
back there hi and I was just go from
when you get your original idea when you
actually start writing the script
obviously with Remo it was different
do you how much of the plot points do
you have in your mind already and do you
do it from beginning to end when you're
writing or do you find it easier to sort
of move around the script a little bit
yeah the in except drama that they will
say completely responsible process of
just going into you know like writing in
a free in a free fall the in the other
screenplays I cannot start writing until
I feel that in my head I had the bits
you know actually pebble by bokov ski he
she talks about your five moments right
you know he talks about you need five
moments and that kiss process - deeper
yes but I understand what he's talking
about Bible talks about you have your
five moments once that you have your
five moments it's just about find him
yeah finding the flowing between those
five moments in my case yes I need to
understand I need to understand how I'm
entering the whole thing I need to
understand the main conflict if your
mind and then I need to understand the
the worries it going to you know so if
not I feel very insecure except Roma but
because then I when I finish the
screenplay because I didn't read it
again to Carlos my brother Ike I kept
I'm saying it says it's a film that is
not narrative I didn't know was
narrative in other words you know and
when he finally his side you said you
cheated because it's it's very narrow
it's very narrative but I kept on
telling he means you know I don't know
if anybody's going to care about it this
guy thing is a very abstract thing but
generally speaking I once that I have
those things is when I can do my three
weeks of just writing so I'm not sure
what the microphone is but we have a
hand up here in the middle thank you
yeah and we'll come to you so there's
another one down here on the third or
fourth round yep
related to a lot of the things you're
talking about about time the
relationship the viewer has and the
writer has the filmmaker has with time I
feel like right now because of the
platforms and not to get too much into
it
sometimes as a writer you have a choice
make your screenplay seventy five
minutes or eight hours and we'll go
either way and if it's eight hours can
you make it forty hours for the next
five years
and you're still thinking of it in terms
of oh I have a story a tizzy I don't
know if I can do five five moments and
fill it in eight hours but it's a
different type of paradigm we're talking
about now that you have a film that can
stretch out so I just want to know your
thought on that do you see a place for
yourself in that world and the idea of a
moment look if you consider that their
only reason why films are two hours long
it's a convention that it has was
inherited in the early silent films
because of commercial considerations and
it was a convention that was inherited
from the body bill and the and and the
theater you know
and also because start making sense in
terms of the kind of amount of showings
that would you could give facility that
you could fit in one day so if you think
about that cinema inherit just something
that is very Philistine you know just
one more time a business model and what
I find that is so exciting nowadays is
that cinemas is going to start to be get
free into exploring uncharted
territories for instance short films we
call it short films when if you think
about it some of the masterpieces of the
silent films or sure are shorter but
they are not short films are films you
know and and when you call short film
you're already doing some you're calling
in a very big jority
wave suggest it's not a full film so and
if you see some words of some amazing
masters our films that sometimes have
ten minutes long or seven minutes long
or fifteen minutes long so I think it's
it's a time to start just erasing those
definitions and also is I remember
there's a great filmmaker German
filmmaker Lucas called see burger that
insular burg use we used to do these
very crazy things with Wagner operas
that they lasted like seven hours you
know and it was just such a trip just to
watch and sit there and get lost in the
madness of that and and right now I
think that that said this great
opportunity now I'm talking about cinema
what we're experiencing around a lot
with platforms is not necessarily cinema
is more is more connected with TV that
is a different thing it's fantastic it's
a great thing I enjoy them and their
rumps and I can get I can do my brain
branch watch but I'm watching I'm
getting lost in a soap or in a in a in a
series but not because of the cinematic
value of the thing I'm getting lost in
the story in many ways is becoming a
media for lazy readers you know it's the
well what I am more intrigued is about
cinema and what if we were you're
talking about of doing stretching your
five moments or turning white 5 moments
why do pebble do 50 moments you know be
more like the war on the piece one piece
you know that one piece is not 5 moments
you know so it's about stretching that
but as long as war and peace has had a
much as much as much literary power as a
short a short story by also Tolstoy that
is a winter night you know and if you
can achieve the whole thing one that in
in what is 50 pages as winter night or
the hundred pages that is warm peace in
a cinematic form now that the platforms
are given that opportunity fantastic and
by the way that's not to put down Siri
hi I enjoy them I'm writing one you know
just because it's so much fun I'm
writing one because it's just you don't
have the constraint of the hours you use
keep on developing your care
you keep on developing story you don't
have to Telegraph stuff I I think it's
amazing
we have someone down here on the third
row yeah I was interested to know what
your advice to screenwriters is on
listening to notes and like when
especially kind of producer and
financier notes and when a useful and
whenever no no listen to them
no no then say great ideas let me think
about them when I'm gone I think I think
you won't get a more concise or acute
answer than that it's there anyone
anyone else with a hand up so in the
middle here could someone get a
microphone but by the same token find
you trusted you trusted collaborators
that are mean to you
and that is fundamental there's nothing
meaner to me that for instance Guillermo
del Toro
no one is fantastic I'm so grateful with
him or pebble that the film about the
early humans pebble read it yep and this
was this how he killed me this
curriculum is it in his polish yep well
thank you so much for that yeah
somewhere in the middle I'm sorry I
can't really see that how do I follow
that and you talked about five moments
and something I completely agree with it
cinema I
what were the five moments that guided
you through gravity Wow I guess it was
it was the triggering the whole thing
into her getting lost in space I'm
pretty much was probably three moments
it was because I there was a point in
which we wanted just to do a whole film
the whole very first idea of cornice and
I betrayed is that there was not going
to be any other character that we see
but there was no the George Clooney
character was you're only going to be
the center character and it was mostly
about hair getting lost in space and
keep on rolling and rolling and rolling
into the void and it pretty much was
that and then getting back into yeah
we're talking about getting lost and we
were talking with the tools that we had
there that we knew that they existed in
over there there was a Hubble telescope
the International Space Station this we
use and they Chinese station because the
Chinese station when we were doing it
they have just launched it and we we
figured that by the time we finished the
movie wouldn't read it and now even felt
you know you see at the end that they
can Gong goes into the atmosphere and
their photos of that is fantastic I mean
it's fantastic because a it happened
yeah I mean it's not a good thing
probably and so those were they those
were the moments and then the whole
thing of you know like her coming back
in earth but yeah it was it was pretty
much structure about there they they the
bases we used to go like the basis the
basis that we have available in space
the reality yeah thank you
are there any other hands up can I see
but each one then while we discuss is in
each one of those bases what was the
emotional value of each one of those
well one is is a sense of rebirth in
other ways is another is a moment of
gestation you know and and at the end is
pretty much the the moment of of of a
birth of reincarnation yeah at the back
somebody's there with a mic hi I really
loved what you said about when you did
the Harry Potter how joy filled it was
and I wondered for you as a writer how
important is Joey ta yeah that'd be you
know a joy is the thing that has to lead
the process and the and and that's
that's in if I have to define the
moments of joy in the in the in the
process of filmmaking for me or filming
him from me is writing again because the
moment that you are alone there are no
limitations there's no constraint of
time there's no constraint of money
unless you have to pay the rent and then
you have to deliver the dress but and
that that is the that is the moment and
it's not only Harry Potter it's just
every single moment of writing it's just
I love when you're you get lost and if
you're you know if you have to travel
you know instead of a getting falling
asleep in the plane or or watching a
movie that is fantastic to watch movies
bad movies in planes not good movies bad
movies and and you cry yes like what's
it yeah like a low-range and it does me
wonders it has recursive you know know
that when you're flying you cry and and
so it is great but you even don't do
that because you just want to keep on
writing yeah and it is just such an
amazing thing and you just get lost in
that in that zone I because from then on
everything goes downhill yes
you know it's just the rest of the
process is painful yes
it's the only moment of infinite
possibility because everything after
that is an interpretation yeah yeah um
there's somebody up at the back I
believe is yes so they're just up there
so the words cinema and cinematic gets
thrown around all the time and I just
want to know what it is to you what is
cinema to you what are those elements
yeah is this this language in which that
that is a language in its own right in
with that in which all of these all of
these other things around are just tools
for that for the sake of that language
and what I'm saying is that you have
seen and there are expressions of
amazing amazing amazing films and
masterpieces that are having done
without sound without music without
color without actors even without
stories but there are not one single
masterpiece that has been done without
images you know and Andy and this is the
thing is the image as a as a image
flowing in time you know and is this
thing of how what matters is are those
images flowing in time and whatever is
there is there that that that is
represented is I'm not really interested
in Illustrated stories you know and
that's the easy thing of a lot of the
series are fantastic and and I love
watching them because I can watch most
of them with my eyes closed
you know I can be doing stuff and I'm
following the show you know once in a
while I come back and he's talking to go
back a little bit
oh wow
is but but most of I have to say most of
contemporary mainstream cinema is the
kind of cinema that you enter the
theater you get your popcorn you sit
down
the lights go off you close your eyes
you do popcorn
the movie ends and you didn't miss one
bit you know it's more like again it's
more like like books for lazy people you
know and when it's about cinematic is
when the dance between the elements a
are greater than the sum of the elements
you know and that is what is amazing
that is what I consider cinematic thank
you time for two more and somebody's
very patiently waited down here the
microphones there so we'll take that
question and then the last one will be
down here at the front thank you
hey Alfonso thank you for the
inspirational conversation I just had a
question about the process of making the
film's when you did know the film with
Netflix Roma was the process different
than when you do it with a classical
studio did they try to influence it in
any way or you had a complete freedom
now the film was not produced by it
Netflix that the film was produced by
Esperanto filmic and participant media
then we sold it to Netflix for
distribution it's a completely I mean
and but even if I if I have doing a film
with Netflix
you know originals they have financed it
from the beginning that wouldn't change
anything I mean it's do you change how
do you do your films if it's going to be
produced by Warner Brothers or 20
Century Fox I think it's so important to
stop like separate you know like those
are economic models again those are just
you know is just they had nothing to do
with with the work of cinema you know I
think that by the way it's a film that
is shot in 65 millimeters with Dolby
Atmos you know obviously was not
no film that I will do is meant to be
seen in as in a telephone you know if
somebody choose it to see it like that
well does their choice but I hope that
people that care about the art of cinema
they will want to see it in a big screen
as I hope that please if you happen to
see Roma please try to see it in a big
screen absolutely
last question down here on the front and
this corresponds to the previous
question about what is cinema and a
cinematic language and your cinematic
language especially Roma is very soulful
it has a kind of Grace and I wondered if
that's an element that you consciously
feed into the writing or it's just
something that comes out of you
naturally and you don't think about it
this so I don't really think about it I
think about the elements I think a lot
about the elements that are going to
compress that it and most of those
elements are in the screenplay
you know and that's the thing is that's
what I love the screenwriting I don't
consider myself a writer in because I
don't know if I could write a book
because what I try to write these is to
provide those elements in the page that
can be transforming to a cinematic
experience you know is and I love I love
the combination of sounds and characters
and dialogue but also of the of the
context of everything that is around so
but also in the page there's I try to
describe a sense of time you know in a I
am NOT a believer of the economic
writing and maybe it's wrong is the
economic writing of the regions minimal
description dialogue minimal description
because I feel that that sometimes lies
in terms of the flow of time I prefer
that if it's going to be
a something that at the end is going to
last say four minutes is represented I'm
on the plane on the pain absolutely you
know absolutely it's a the the and and
that is what I don't love screenplays
when they just described that there's
going to be a very big battle and and
they use field words to to convey a
sense of battle because a battle itself
is a structuring time yes so even even
again as if the director is not going to
follow every single one of the beads
that in the page to have that sense of
the rhythm in how that battle is going
to is going to flow it's not enough to
say the army marches into town sorry
there you go yeah just before we finish
I wanted to ask you Alfonso what your
contemporary self now would say to your
younger self if you had one word of
advice you guys always do that what
would you say when we're doing that what
what would you what would you say to me
yeah that's a good piece yeah talk to
gehrman on that on that happy note
I'm sure Guillermo is ready to take
everyone's calls I would just like to
say from all of our hearts thank you so
so much you have been so generous
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]